and please bear with us as we get the
live stream started as you can see matt
is here and ready
to start the webinar for you so
one moment please
okay
all right and our live stream has
started
welcome everyone to our expert webinar
our last simply learn webinar of 2021
and we'll be looking ahead to digital
marketing trends in 2022
with matt bailey the founder and
president of sitelogic marketing it's a
member of our digital marketing faculty
at simplylearn so we're very glad to
have him
and
a
little preliminary before we start the
actual
presentation
i want to move to the next slide matt oh
yep
sorry
that's on you that's on you today um i'm
driving yes yeah
um first off my name is stuart creek i'm
a marketing manager here at simply learn
and i'm gonna let you know that you
should put your questions as soon as you
think of a question for matt please put
it in the q a box and i'll be taking uh
making a list of those to ask him in the
q a
portion of the session toward the end
you can put in chat information um
but the questions should go in the q a
box that way we'll be sure to see them
sometimes the chat gets crowded
uh and next
i just want to say we have
polls
at a couple places in the webinar
we will start with this simple poll
uh let's matt know a little bit about
the audience how much work experience do
you have
and we've actually added a category here
um so you can
answer
more than ten years six to ten three to
five one to two
and also we ask how you're doing because
as the pandemic grinds on
it can take a toll so we want to make
sure that people are holding up
and fortunately it looks today like
almost everyone is
so in two seconds
i will share with you
the poll results
and
what it says is about a third of our
audience is uh season professionals with
more than 10 years of experience
but about a quarter of the audience are
people who are still in
college or university
so it's a good distribution
also it's nice to see that
pretty much everybody is doing well or
in the middle for the people who are not
feeling so happy today i hope that this
webinar gives you information that will
uh brighten your perspective for the
coming year because that's the
that's the intent so let's move on
and i want to introduce matt who you see
on your screen and he is the president
of sitelogic
a digital marketing instructor for the
dma in new york and
uh instructor for the online marketing
certified professional program
and the author of several books internet
marketing an hour a day wired to be
wowed and teach old dog new dogs old
tricks i'm sorry
and
and um
he is as i mentioned a member of the
digital marketing faculty so welcome
matt
and thank you for being here
all right thank you so much stuart i
always look forward to doing this and i
look forward to our webinars here
and uh so
what i've been asked to cover is my
views on what's happening
trends for maybe next year or the next
few years that in digital marketing we
need to know we need to be aware of uh
and also if you are working within an
organization this is something where you
need to have a handle on the new
technology and what's happening so that
you can plan accordingly so i've got a
number of things i want to cover today
and we're going to go a little fast so
if you want me to address anything
specifically about what i've said put it
in the chat box
i'm going to keep a little bit of an eye
on that but stuart's gonna watch it and
then afterwards we're gonna have time
for q a or we can dig in a little bit
deeper and that's where we can get into
some real practical
questions about what it is that we
that you want and that i can provide
some information to you
first of all here's what's going to
happen over the next few years because
it's been happening
slowly
kind of undercover right now but now
it's coming out into the open and that
is that big tech is going to have a very
antagonistic relationship
okay let's start with google alright
google
earlier
started this core web vitals okay which
is a large technical change to the
algorithm this was a major change
in an algorithm for the results that
forced website owners to make changes
and changes to the technical side now
this hasn't happened for quite a while a
lot of this
prior to this has been in accessibility
of programming
those types of things of making sure
your site can be spidered but now we
have google saying it has to be fast it
has to load a certain way
here's the problem
for example i use wordpress
wordpress i'm limited to what wordpress
can do and so a lot of core web vital
type optimization i can't perform i need
wordpress to do it because wordpress is
my content management system it's my
website manager and wordpress
really came out and and they power more
than 40 of websites online and wordpress
said we're not changing anything
and so when all of a sudden people start
pushing back and saying we're not gonna
change because of google
there's gonna be a problem uh over 50
percent of the top 100 sites fail core
web vitals and you know what they don't
have any plans to change they're not
reacting to what google wants them to do
and this might some of you might
remember last year when we did this wrap
up the big news was
google's flock the federation federated
learning of cohorts which was google's
replacement for the cookie
and you know what happened
amazon said they're not going to support
flock because that gives google the
ability to see what people are doing on
amazon.com and so amazon said we're not
going to support it wordpress said we're
not going to support it and they were
coming out with plugins that you could
block google's tracking on your website
if it was wordpress and this started
across the internet major properties
were saying we're not going to support
google in this we're not going to make
changes just because they want it
so this has been the second major change
that google has made to try and force
the industry into a standard and the
industry is resisting
another reason why is because
what google has done to publishers
google has reduced publisher
revenue because of their ads because
years ago they made them go to amp pages
and publishers put millions of dollars
in developing amp pages
but now with core web vitals and the
changes google's is main google is
saying well there's no more amp pages
and so now they've cost publishers
millions of dollars to conform to a
google standard to which google has
immediately just removed
so there's a lot of antagonistic
issues going on between google and the
rest of the industry that supports it
and this is going to be interesting to
watch because more and more companies uh
large companies are having a problem
with letting google just do what they
want to do
another issue in this came out uh with a
number of lawsuits against google and
now these lawsuits
are against facebook as well and what
they are accusing them of
is what's essentially called price
fixing
and that is where google and facebook
had a secret relationship
that they wouldn't compete with each
other but if there was ad space that
facebook would get a discount for their
ads before it would go to other
advertisers
and
this is amazing there's been redacted
documents come out about this and
there's a lot of lawsuits coming out as
well that focus on
this exact thing that's happening so
there's going to be a lot of issues with
google and in fact every month we're
seeing more and more
anti-google as well as anti-facebook
content hitting the news
now speaking of facebook let's look at
social media
a major retailer here in the u.s pulled
out of social media entirely
lush is a bath and body products
retailer and around the end of november
they said they were completely
shutting down all of their social media
because
lush their
uh brand is all about relaxing self-care
take care of yourself unplug and relax
and they said being on social media does
not fit the brand because social media
does so much to a it's an addictive
algorithm uh it keeps you online it
keeps you engaged and it won't let you
unplug and they said that doesn't fit
our brand
and so we're seeing more and more of a
backlash
against these addictive algorithms that
keep you
tuned into the feed and so
again we're seeing more awareness about
this more of a mental health awareness
especially when facebook now admits that
they know that instagram and the
facebook feeds have caused mental health
issues
their own research has shown it and now
other researchers are seeing it as well
now
from
let's look at it now from a content
creator standpoint
for content creators that create content
on facebook instagram youtube
uh linkedin any of the the social media
anyone who creates content
number one
what you are doing is you are giving
your content to a third party you're
giving it to that social media network
and all social media networks are now
reducing the visibility of content that
has an external link
what that means is if i'm a content
creator
and i post an article or i post a video
and i link it to my website
it will reduce the visibility less
people will see that content because it
has an external link
if i produce and load content that has
no external link more people will see it
so now
now we don't have a friendly
relationship you see in the past
that wouldn't be diminished in the past
i could build an audience on social
media and link it to my website and not
be penalized for it however over the
past few years
all the algorithms have merged into
keeping people on that
platform on that
social news feed
and they don't want people to leave
so
now we have again another antagonistic
relationship i can't build my business
effectively because they're diminishing
my links
i can if i want to be successful i need
to create content that they
own
because it's on their
network
and now it's whose content is it
whose content am i building am i truly
building my own and i might get paid for
it i might get some sponsorships i might
get paid by youtube but ultimately it's
their content on their platform and i'm
getting a little bit for it
so
social media
creating content and posting content on
social media has changed dramatically
because of their maintaining this closed
bubble and you can't build like you used
to it's different and you have to view
it that way
that now i'm using social media
as i tell people you're using social
media the way they use you
all right they're using you to sell
products to put ads in front of and they
get paid when they show ads
so i'm going to use social media to
build my lists i'm going to put links
but i'm going to add content knowing
that they take ownership of that content
and it helps their business it gives
them more
content to keep people engaged
uh now second aspect is privacy and if
you're not watching this game you're
missing out
privacy these are just the headlines
from the past year and there's more that
didn't make it in this list okay
um
look at all of the big tech names in
here uh grinder was probably the most
recent find over 6 million euro for
sharing data without consent
and that's anyone who had the app any
registered user of the app they were
sharing that data with advertisers they
were sharing that data with third
parties without consent uh zoom
was fined for sharing data google
collecting biometric data on students
um whatsapp for sharing data and look
how many times google shows up in here
um facebook find tick tock find uh and
and so it's amazing how much big tech is
overstepping privacy existing privacy
laws and let me tell you the existing
privacy laws
are very
liberal they are they they're not good
they need to be improved for this new
digital commerce age
the privacy laws we have are antiquated
and they don't cover everything
but even still big tech is still
overstepping and
we the amount of fines and lawsuits
going on against big tech it's worldwide
now the last thing i want to draw your
attention to
is programmatic advertising and
real-time bidding has been called the
biggest data breach in human history
all right now if you don't understand
what that means let me explain it to you
now
anytime you see an ad
on the web page wherever you go whenever
you see an ad
what happens is
a an ad server
wants to know which ad fits you
it's all customized they want to know
which ad to place there for you to see
they need to fill that rectangle in
order to make money
now in order to know who you are and
what ad is going to fit
they extract a certain amount of
information
and that's from cookies that's from your
browser data that's from your device
data all right now this is the ad spec
okay and this is from the iab which is
the interactive advertising bureau which
is the
the worldwide
ad tech
uh i would say the worldwide ad tech uh
standard and this is exactly the same as
google's spec you can find it on their
website and it's the ad com spec
now
when an ad is to be loaded on the page
here is the information that they are
getting number one
the website you are on
now and it's interesting because they
they say example site this is every site
you're on
so
any site
and and you're gonna get a sense of what
i mean when i focus on that number one
are you on mobile
uh and if so look your id now this is
your ad id this identifies you
uh as a user and one that they know of i
can't write d
at id
um
this builds your profile online your
individual profile
then
check this out you think that now we
have specifically user
your user id your buyer id year of birth
gender these are all included in the ad
spec
then
device and this right here your ifa if
you're on a mobile device
this singles you out because this is
unique to every single mobile device
they know the make they know the model
they know
uh the hardware the operating system the
operating system
version
and and that's the thing and now we're
look at all these data points that are
about you and this gets shared
to everyone that wants to put an ad on
the page
not only this look at this
the latitude and longitude
of where you're at
this gets transmitted to every
ad tech
company that wants to put an ad in front
of you
on every page you visit every time
there's an ad on the page now how many
times have you been on a page where
there's 20 ads or more
and because they're
monetizing all of this let me show you
something
this is the what's called the audience
taxonomy what that means is all of this
data all right they take all this data
they send it to
a big database
the big database you may be aware of it
this is called the dmp
all right the data management platform
all of this data is condensed into
what's called the dmp
and also based on the websites you visit
they put you into a category and here
are the categories check this out look
at this
they have categories
diabetes
epilepsy heart disease
and and and look at this incest or abuse
support incontinence and if you are
looking into any medical condition
online you are automatically assigned to
a specific audience
about what type of ailment you might be
looking for
also
anything you might be looking at so
right away what this should show us is
ad tech is tracking things
that legally doctors aren't allowed to
disclose
and so they know more about you than
your doctor than other people they know
what religion you are they know what
medical uh issues you are facing and and
this is just the top
of the categories
that
people are collecting that that ad tech
is collecting on you and this is part
now of the profile
now
this is one ad request all right for one
ad to go on a page
all right and and so let's put our
internet page here and let's look
specifically this ad
one ad request well that ad request goes
out on the auction
and what they're saying is who wants to
bid on this ad and we can see here it
goes out and now we have probably about
20 or 30 other ad tech companies bidding
on getting that ad in there
well
just one of these ad tech companies
sends it out to another auction and this
one by itself is responsible
for now sending out your data to
hundreds of other companies
just this one
broker here
has now sent your data out to all these
companies and this is what they mean
that this is the biggest data breach in
human history
all of this data about you is being
transmitted to thousands of companies a
day
every time you go online
who you are what content you're
interested in reading every website you
visit every piece of content you visit
is assigned to this profile and it's
being shared
this is
right now a lot of governments don't
understand it or they don't want to hear
it but this is getting harder and harder
to ignore because also this has a lot to
do with fraud
in the ad industry and so this is
something you need to be aware of keep
an eye on it and watch it because if you
are the digital marketing representative
in your company you need to be able to
talk about this competently and
understand what's happening
all right enough for that section we're
going to lighten it up in the second
section uh so we've got another poll
here i would like to know what's your
area of specialty or what are you most
interested in learning here with this
poll stuart if you could pop that up
there please
we have a companion question for people
who are
watching through
the webex live
the companion question is when would you
like to start
and
we are
10 seconds away from closing the poll so
please get your answers in
and here are the answers it's a pretty
broad distribution of the skills you'd
like that people want to have yeah
and
almost half the audience wants to start
right away so that's a good sign because
now is always a good time to start
in the right place
all right
well you could probably tell uh privacy
and this antagonistic relationship those
are two things i get emotional about
because it has so much to do with
respect of people um
and i i i think big tech has become
further and further disconnected
with reality uh and with real people and
so now the second part i'm gonna drill
down a little more into some specific
things and discipline related
information that we need to be aware of
for the upcoming couple of years number
one seo
uh let's look at the google results i
just put in a city here of dubai
um
look at what happens
google and and this has been happening
for years google is turning its its
results page into a destination
and so if you're trying to get a website
to rank well in google you need to know
what these what's going on in the
results
evaluate the results pages for the words
you're trying to rank for and look
what's there we've got the local pack
all right we've got uh the one box that
will show up
who's there what's there and you'll
notice even in the one box and this gets
into local seo and google my business
you've got images you've got information
you've got a lot of questions and
information that's there
also uh we've got the people also ask
we've got images and top stories
so it's not enough now just to get a
website on the first page of google
your optimization needs to cover a wide
range of content if you're not also
optimizing news articles
that will show up there as well as in
the news tab if you're not optimizing
your images uh or if your e-commerce
your shopping feeds anything like that
you need to optimize for the google
results page and all of the content and
all the media types that are on there so
it's no longer just the website you need
to be concerned about it's looking to
see what's all the competition that's
there
now for seo
what we're seeing and this is some
tweets that were made by john mu of from
google earlier just last week okay
and it's interesting because he talks
about um seo and prioritizing it all
right and it's very i love what he says
here it's easy to find uh whoops let me
get back to that my marker didn't work
it's easy to find 100 things to do for
seo
but which one is the right one to focus
on and then he say he makes this
statement and this blew people's minds
you can't even tell afterwards
what he's saying is you can have a
hundred things to do
but once you get that done you don't
know what it was that got you the
rankings
it could be one thing it could be 10
things
that's part of xco and it is
prioritizing
prioritizing your seo
like he says you can have a hundred
things to do but what are you going to
do today
that's seo um like he said here some
things are easy
fixing a technically broken and seeing
it rank that's obvious that's the easy
part
but what about after that and here we
come down
seo expertise in seo requires experience
the more experience you have the more
you've seen things the more you've
worked on things the more you've worked
in different industries or different
areas it all adds up because the
experience will help you figure out what
to prioritize and what to do first and
so for seo it becomes really a
never-ending learning experience
from every site you work on from
everything that you do and looking at
those results and learning
seo is not just something you do it's
something you fully engage in
and you look at the results of
everything you do
it's it's it's one of those professions
that you learn from something every time
you work in it
so if your seo skills or knowledge are
not expanding because you're just
you're just executing and okay you're
just pushing buttons and pushing it out
rather than
learning from it and seeing what's
working what's not working what's wrong
with this site how do we fix that it's
that constant
development of skills to analyze what
needs to be done and then prioritize how
it should be done and then evaluate the
results
now next thing mobile
uh mobile is big and we all know it and
over 70 percent of e-commerce sales are
on mobile devices and especially with
the pandemic what is amazing to me as
more businesses have started
in and because of the pandemic people
are starting more businesses than ever
and so there's going to be a demand for
people who know how to build websites
people who know how to optimize websites
and by the way people who know how to
build mobile all right so it's so
critical not only is the site mobile
friendly
but let's talk about usability
and just because you use a website
builder does not mean your website is
the most usable
a lot of website builders or even if you
use a template or a theme
a lot of the people that build those are
good artists and they're good designers
but they may not understand usability or
conversion
optimization is what we call that
what that means is you need to know if
you use a theme or a template what do
you need to change in order to improve
the conversion rate are the button sizes
too small is the text not readable uh
you know is the color scheme not able to
be read properly understanding those
areas of usability and applying it
especially in mobile
because mobile you have less
leeway for mistakes
the next area especially in mobile and
this is one of the areas where i watch
very closely and that is
people's confidence in using checkout on
mobile if people aren't confident
that their transaction is secure that
they see all of the information or that
it's easy to understand then they won't
do it
and so
as you develop sites as you create them
and this gets into the conversion
optimization
but it is giving those signals to users
that it's okay that it's good and
helping them along and making them
confident that it's going to work
now the other side of this is what's
called social commerce and it's very
interesting because over the past
oh i would say more than 10 years every
year when when i see trends and when i
see what people are predicting
every year for the past
10 or more years
they have said watch out social commerce
is going to explode
and you know what hasn't happened over
the past 10 or more years
social commerce hasn't exploded it's
been a slow trickle up it's not been the
big overwhelming flood that they said it
would be
and here's why
even in china
they top out at about 50 percent of
people have bought from social commerce
in the u.s it's about 30
but here's the question that they ask
people in order to get that data have
you made at least one purchase on social
commerce
that is a very low bar
what this then says is 30 percent of
people in the us have made at least one
purchase on social commerce
now
most of those
have been in games all right those of
you that play mobile games and you need
that boost and you want to buy something
that's considered social commerce and so
uh if if you're familiar with candy
crush they made over 1 billion dollars
this year
in people buying boosts and lives and
things like that that's social commerce
so china is at 50
uh
and and here's the thing
the analytics
i i always go to analytics
people are more confident
and overwhelmingly prefer
to shop direct on a brand website or a
retailer website
than a social feed
they're not confident and and part of it
too is is like on facebook or instagram
facebook's reputation is taking a big
big hit instagram along with it
am i confident in using checkout on
instagram am i confident on using the
checkout on tick tock
am i confident with those things
i would rather go to the retailer site
and buy it from them
and chances are i'll get a discount
coupon when i do it and so the the
studies the analytics show that even
though
uh the amount of people who have made
at least one purchase on a social site
is increasing slowly
they'd rather
go to the retailer or go to that site
and do it rather than through the social
site so social commerce still has a lot
of
uh more and more brands are doing it and
i think it's one of those things where
that's the trend but the data doesn't
follow
the data's not following that
and and here's one of the reasons why
uh and this is google's biggest
competitor is amazon
because amazon gets 40 54
of product searches
people that are in want information go
to google people looking for product
information or to buy something they go
to amazon
and that is google's biggest competition
all right i've been seeing in the tech
and the in the chat a couple people have
asked about the metaverse all right
before uh yeah just before you go on to
that i wanted to to make one other
question about social
commerce
all right um one of the interesting
things about
buying something off of facebook is that
there's so
much actual fraud in terms of
companies advertising a product
um that they know isn't
real
yes so
yeah you've seen you've seen the people
the people who
order something and they get a miniature
version of it
that happened to my wife and me and two
different transactions i got a uh
i ordered uh
a adult men's shirt and got a child's
shirt in the
shipment from china so
that type of thing
yes containers
contaminates the whole
sector for everybody oh absolutely
absolutely there is a lot of that um
and uh actually i just worked with an
e-commerce company trying to figure this
out over the past few weeks
um they were getting orders but the
email address did not match the
purchaser's name
um and what we found out is this company
had set up a store
and was selling these products at
ridiculously
cheap prices
people were buying them thinking they
were getting a great deal
well then the people that set up the
store
they would buy them from other retailers
with stolen credit cards
and then ship it
to whoever bought it i i'm looking at
that as we're figuring this out and
working through it i'm like this takes
so much work to do
um and then what would happen is
the chargeback would go against uh
the the client that i was working with
when they found out that their credit
card was being fraudulently used uh
there would be a charge back and it
would be the legitimate retailer was out
of the money so there's a lot of fraud
and a lot of things that's going on in
social retail that you've got to watch
out for absolutely
all right
uh let's talk about metaverse um
number one how many of you remember
second life
how many of you remember that that was
about 10 years ago um
second life was a vr world
and
it wasn't particularly attractive it was
very blocky
um
and it attracted a a group of people and
and this was called the greatest thing
ever and it was ushering in the the
virtual reality age
and everything i'm hearing about
metaverse i heard 10 years ago about
second life
there were businesses buying
virtual real estate in second life there
was a virtual times square
there were virtual uh stores that brands
were investing in and they were spending
millions of dollars in this second life
and building this virtual and and then
do you ever hear about second life ever
again
no
uh it was a fad
and honestly metaverse is proposed by
zuckerberg here but the reality of
metaverse is years away
it his vision is years away
uh intel
has said uh they came out and said the
metaverse in order to power it the way
they're talking about
we need 1 000 times the current
computational efficiency that means
technically we're not there yet we're
nowhere near that
um
and then also it requires third party
hardware
and who dominates that market
meta or facebook
they own the hardware and if facebook
owns the hardware
um and they also own everything that
goes on there that means and here's the
thing facebook is all about monetizing
your attention everything you look at in
the metaverse is now added to your
personal profile
everything you view everything you if
your gaze goes on something they know
you're interested in it and they'll try
and sell it to you
um
so ultimately who owns the metaverse
and
honestly any technology
that relies on third-party
interfaces
is a problem
that never really takes off an example
of that was the qr code
qr code came out years ago but guess
what it was not native to a mobile
device
you had to download an app in order to
use the qr code correctly and so the qr
code never took off
then comes the pandemic and guess what
qr code readers are now native in the
mobile device and they're used
everywhere qr code is fantastic because
i don't want to touch the menu so i use
my phone i get the qr code i can see the
menu on my phone
there's no longer a third party
interface there's nothing i need to
download or buy or acquire in order to
use it and that's the problem when we
start talking about technology um so
we've got
hardware issues we've got and and by the
way in order to buy the hardware in
order to participate in the metaverse
we're establishing a tiered system
already those with the money those with
the hardware those with the
computational efficiency that means
those with the high-end pcs are the ones
who are going to be able to use it
effectively
now i will say this i have participated
in a vr lecture uh i've done some vr
uh
training and it was interesting it was
very interesting
could i see everything moving to that
someday
possibly um but nothing replaces seeing
actual humans and human interaction um
it is a substitute and it will always be
a substitute uh depending upon what's
happening so
i'm not i'm i'm sitting on the sidelines
watching this you may be more willing to
jump in and see what's happening and i'm
fine with that go ahead play around see
what it is
but be aware of who's involved and how
are they going to monetize all this
because it's going to take billions of
dollars to build this
all right
last poll all right and i'm going to
challenge you on this uh especially if
you are in digital marketing uh we're in
the last uh
bit of our webinar here but i would like
to ask you about how would you define
an impression
stuart if you could put that poll up
there
this is my challenge to you i want to
know how do you define
an impression
one moment
all right
so give everyone a chance to read these
hold on hold on for just a moment
there was a
disconnect between
that's all right here it goes
oh boy
that's all right i got a lot of response
in the chat here people are putting in
their answers in the chat which i
appreciate that's good to see
all right so
the reason why i asked this question
when i go and train companies even when
i go to a
a marketing team
i will ask this question and what i am
amazed at is that even within
one company
there are many different definitions of
an impression
what that means is
marketing has won
even in the marketing department
people in the marketing department have
different
definitions of an impression
and the problem is how can we
effectively measure something
when we don't have a consistent
understanding and definition of what an
impression
is
all right and an impression is like the
beginning of anything digital
so stuart don't worry about that we'll
just go through it here i i've got a lot
of i'll let everyone self correct here
all right
appreciate that thank you that's all
right that's all right okay so let me
give you and and and i'll just i'm not
going to
go too much into this but i will say
this
i'm not going to say it's right however
see
all right i'm looking at the chat to see
because of everyone c
is facebook's definition of an
impression
it is spotify's
definition of an impression it is
instagram
it is tick tock
it is
anyone that is in the ad tech all right
anyone
that is selling ads
selling impressions
this is their definition
their definition is anything with
greater than zero pixels is shown for
more than zero seconds that is the ad
tech definition and so within your
company
within your company if you are buying
ads if you are paying for impressions
then your definition needs to be the
same
as the company you are buying from those
buying those impressions
because if it's anything other
than
it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter you could a b or c
those could be used within your
organization but if they don't match
what you're paying for
then you're no one is understanding
what's happening and so
number one when we start talking about
careers and the opportunity that's going
on right now
it's in understanding this data
understanding digital and how it applies
here's how i'm going to finish over the
next few minutes there is a skills gap
all right and this is a huge opportunity
this article just came out
yesterday
that there is a gap a digital skills gap
all right look at this marketer's
abilities and key digital skills have
either stagnated or declined between
2020 and 2021 at all
levels
all levels
there is a digital skills gap and it
goes right back to what i talked about
in the earlier slide we don't have a
consistent definition of impression and
an impression is the basis of digital
marketing
so if we don't understand that and we
don't apply it within an organization or
measuring the wrong things we're
thinking the wrong things or approaching
problems uh without a solid
understanding of what we're trying to do
right now there is
linkedin uh jobs has put out uh their
top five skills in demand by employers
seo
paid search paid advertising and
analytics are four of the top five
skills in demand right now
and unfortunately in the marketplace
there is a lack of skilled marketers
there's a lack of understanding
especially in analytics
that right there and i see this all the
time i train companies
weekly
and analytics is their weakest strength
it's their weakest area and when you
don't understand analytics you're not
doing seo effectively you're not doing
paid search effectively you're not doing
content marketing effectively you're not
doing any marketing effectively if you
don't understand analytics uh by the way
i i would like to put this um
where was this
uh
i did a recent podcast with brad gettys
those of you who are enrolled in simply
learn courses uh you know who brad
gettys is and uh let me see let me post
that here because i would highly highly
recommend um
because brad himself even you know we
both talked about this and uh we both
agree that analytics by far is
the most uh critical skill uh that is
that is needed right now for marketers
let me copy that and
see if i can get that in the chat
what's happening to my chat okay
all right so there's a link to the
podcast that i did with brad uh those of
you that are following brad are in his
courses you won't be surprised at some
of the things he says uh but we both
agree analytics is
a critical skill moving forward and so
here's the opportunity the opportunity
is certifications are growing
uh they are more important than ever
they are more important than college
degrees to many employers because a
certification shows that you have
specific skills that have been validated
by an exam by testing by experience that
is what's critical so so a college
degree
i can have a degree in marketing but it
doesn't show i know how to optimize a
site doesn't know it doesn't show i know
how to create a paid search campaign
so these certifications are becoming
more and more important as well as
continuing education always learning
more finding people you know podcasts
training additional you know keeping up
in the industry with who's doing things
and and this work from home is going to
continue for a lot of years i i think
work from home is now here to stay
because of that
invest and and i'll tell you this
because you're going to do a lot more
presenting
you've got to be on camera
and if you are working from home and
whether you are working in an
organization or whether you are working
freelance
you're the brand
you are your own brand and so your
camera always needs to be on you always
need to be visible and that means
invest in a good camera
in lighting and in a microphone
because these are now your window to the
world how you sound how you look
at your background everything is part of
your brand either in a company or
freelance so invest invest in those
things and that will go afar
in establishing not only what you say
but
your image what's going on around you
that will establish your credibility and
so these are very very important things
all right we've got a few minutes left
for your q a and i'm also willing to
hang around for a few extra minutes as
well
just so you know stuart i don't know
what your schedule is but
i've got a few extra minutes and i now's
the best part i want your questions
great
uh first off i'm going to say that i'm
having a little technical difficulty in
looking at the chat right now so until
that clears up i'll just stick with the
questions that have come in so far but
there's quite a few um
there's an interesting to
set up for for the discussion
uh one of our
audience members asks what is digital
marketing so if you could give an idea
of
there's a follow-up question from
another member
how is digital marketing different from
digital publishing so if you could give
a kind of a
foundational thing all right
about digital marketing
um i'm gonna make it as basic as
possible
digital
marketing is the
[Laughter]
wow it is um
persuading people to do something
that's what marketing is i'll just say
marketing let's take away digital it's
the ability
to influence people
to take an action
that's marketing
um it's it's persuasion at its core
and in a digital aspect i'm asking
people to do something
and and how effective am i in
influencing that action
that thought or that decision
and so digital marketing is all about
influencing an action now we can get
further in influencing a trackable
action
uh but if i'm trying to change people's
attitudes or thoughts that's part of
marketing as well so i would say at its
most basic it's the ability to influence
uh
the ability to influence an action or or
behavior
or a thought
and
the difference between that and digital
publishing is digital publishing is
putting out
your views or your content or your
information
and
thinking that
when somebody accesses and reads that
they're going to make a uh
they're going to have a change in
attitude but digital marketing is is
more proactive than that um because
yeah so go ahead digital publishing so i
work with a publisher's organization and
these publishers so like one of them
publishes about
uh acquisitions like companies that are
acquiring other companies and they
publish who's acquiring who how to get
your business acquired or or how to
acquire and so they found a niche of
information that's valuable to other
people and they they publish and they
sell
that information to
that audience um and so digital
publishing is more the ability to to
take content and put it online and build
an audience
[Music]
so christian asks how do you define a
good digital marketer and what are the
basic requirements to succeed
wow
a good digital marketer okay here is
what i look for and i'll just go through
like kind of what i when i had my agency
i like people who ask good questions
um because if you ask good questions
that shows me that you're thinking
analytically
and if you think analytically as i said
analytics is the number one lacking
skill in marketers today
and it's not that you need to understand
data tables you need to do com you know
comparative analytics you need to
understand the big stuff
i'm just talking about basic stuff being
able to get and understand what you're
seeing in a google analytics or in
uh any analytics program you understand
how to navigate how to get that top
level data
but i when people ask questions
good questions
i get into organizations and when i'm
working with a marketing team what i'm
teaching them to do
is to ask questions because the better
questions you ask the more you define
the project the more you understand
well what have we dealt with in the past
and how do we use that to plan for the
future i i
that to me is probably the number one
and i wouldn't even say that's of a
digital marketer that's of any
uh any employee who is curious about
what are we doing why are we doing it
how do we do it better
and
digging into truly understanding what
they're doing those are the ones i love
working with
great
um
we have a couple of questions about
people asking about the cookie-less
future and whether google has given up
on it
no google's not given up on it because
that gives google
close to a monopoly on all online
advertising if it goes cookie lists
um
because
if it goes cookie lists
every google property and
every google technology is tracking
so chrome browsers android operating
systems
uh
google sheets
uh
the google captcha how many websites is
that on uh google analytics how many
websites is that on so any anyone who
has allowed
any google property to
be on their site like google anal like
google analytics or google captcha
what you've done is you put the google
pixel you put google tracking and that's
so
what that does is solidify a a complete
uh monopoly and so i i think
it's going to be interesting to see how
this plays out i don't see
we're going to go completely cookie-less
however we've also got the
the data privacy part of it
and
over the next few years we're going to
see what's
what's more important to governments
getting along with google
or
enforcing privacy for citizens
that's going to be the fight over the
next few years and that will determine
what we see in cookies
or lack of cookies
one of our audience members was
shocked i probably i would say that i
was shocked as well to see the
level of detail of personal information
that
is
tracked into each
ad request and
so
the question from the
audience member is
isn't it illegal to collect user data
without their permission
you give your permission
um
and and
i think part of it is people don't
understand how much data is being
collected
even and even these websites that say
uh
um
you know approve cookies
or even limit the cookies
if you don't read the terms of service
then
that's where it gets you because in the
terms of service it will say we share
data and anytime you see third party or
partners
that means they're giving your data to
whoever they want
if they say you know we just
you don't just pull up any terms of
service and do a word search for partner
or third party
if that shows up that means they're
giving your data to whoever they want
um
and and no people don't understand the
extent of the tracking that's happening
uh and
and even if you say no decline i don't
want my data shared it's going it's
happening um and so no this is this is
radicalized me um i'm in the industry
and i hate this so yes
we have a question from rishika who asks
you know well
doesn't using incognito mode help
no
all it does incognito mode only whole
hides what you're doing from people in
your own house
google still tracks it
everyone still tracks it um
all it does is delete your cookies after
the session
uh it doesn't maintain the cookie data
but
uh it still tracks your individual
device it tracks the browser tracks all
that it knows you're in in canadian mode
too
um so yeah
it's only good for shopping for gifts
for other people if you use a shared
computer and that way people don't see
what you're shopping for
that's a good point um
i did see vpn vpn does help um a little
bit but it still knows what browser
you're using uh all you're pushing off
is really kind of the uh
location data and some of the things so
vpn can help um just depends on the vpn
uh linkedin watcher is asking if
artificial intelligence automatic
artificial intelligence
will help
assist in digital marketing
or
does further maturation does the market
need to mature more before that becomes
everyone needs to mature more um
you should see the t-shirt i'm wearing
ai is doing some good stuff however it's
dependent upon the quality and the
amount of data given to the ai
to do it
um and and so it's still a lot of day i
still requires manual input because it's
not doing things right um or it's
learning and it is so
it's still got it's doing some small
things well
it's doing large things
okay
it's doing big things
not quite well um
that that's where it's at with that
okay
um
we have a question from another linkedin
watcher who
says do you agree that what makes it
difficult for a digital marketer to
succeed is that they may be good in the
technical part but they lack the sense
of a marketer as you mentioned in terms
of content analytics and asking the good
questions
so understanding the marketing side
rather than the digital uh technical
side
yeah well
so
this is what we call the soft skills
that you can understand technically how
everything works
but
if you
need to communicate that to get someone
to approve it
that takes sales skills that takes
face-to-face marketing skills to
persuade someone to let you do the
campaign
once the campaign's done
now you have to communicate
how well did the campaign do here's the
benefit here's what it here's how it
impacted your uh
your business and this is not just
uh
and this is the problem i i see in
digital marketing or and marketing as a
whole
marketers are typically looked down on
in organizations
because they're the big idea people
there are the people that come in and
look at this latest technology we need
to be in the metaverse or we need to be
on tick-tock and they're doing all these
things but the problem is the rest of
the organization sees marketing
as
they get money and they waste it
because what is marketing bringing to
the table what are they creating what
are they producing in terms of revenue
and profit
and so marketing doesn't get
a full seat at the table and so it's on
marketers to understand how to
communicate what they've done
in terms
that management understands which means
i need to focus on how did i financially
impact the business
what did i do
that created revenue
on top of what would have been created
already
and so
by doing this campaign i created this
here's the revenue here's the profit
until marketers learn the management
language of revenue
they're always going to be seen as sort
of the
uh the the the part of the company that
spends a lot of money on shiny things
yep and and it's important not just to
understand it but to to
uh
make that part of your mindset so that
you're you're not thinking of marketing
as well we're creating awareness we're
you need to think of marketing as well
we're creating revenue and
ultimately profit so yeah yeah um
we have a question from the youtube
channel uh
what would you advise to a marketer
who's worked offline and loves marketing
but doesn't know where to start the
adventure of digital marketing
wow
i you know what you can apply so much of
traditional marketing
you can make an immediate impact
starting with strategy
because
so many marketing departments that i
work with they love the execution they
love the
you know let's create a campaign on paid
search let's create a campaign on
instagram let's create a campaign here
and what they lack is the understanding
of strategy
of that top level what are we trying to
produce
are we presenting this the right way
and that's where digital marketers are
sometimes so focused on a channel or a
discipline that they don't understand
the strategic parts of it
um for example i go back to the four ps
a lot and the four ps are taught as a
basic in marketing price product
promotion um forgetting the fourth one
uh look on my whiteboard i think a
product price placement and promotion
i'll go back to that all the time
because that's taught as
marketing but your average
digital marketer has no understanding of
that
are we promoting it correctly are we
priced competitively are we in the right
place
uh what's our product uh different so
as a traditional marketer you can bring
a lot of those traditional strategic
understanding of big picture
and how are we going to now order our
digital efforts
going into digital is not hard because
all digital is is more channels
that's it uh so how do you make those
channels play together
uh
we have another question from the
youtube
channel
what are the core team positions in a
digital marketing agency or department
[Laughter]
wow
wow i mean i know that that some
agencies or departments consist of one
person with all hats but yes you know
what would the ideal be in terms of if
you had a
the ability to build out a team
all right
um well i think i had a pretty good team
when i had my agency
and
the the cornerstone was a good analyst
i had a good analyst that that's all
they did was analytics and diving into
it they were just a phenomenal
phenomenal
amazing analyst
um
because they analyzed our clients in
terms of conversion optimization they
were always looking at
where you know what's the funnel where
are we losing people how do we fix that
so he wasn't just an analyst he was an
analyst in terms of how do we make it
better how do we create more revenue
those types of things and that's what
made it amazing
now i had content writers
um content writers that worked and
uh strategists
and the strategists were really really
good in content i usually had people
with a pr background uh that were
working directly with clients and
strategizing what this is going to look
like and so they would deal with
the content calendar uh the media that
we're going to produce what it's going
to look like how we're going to do it um
but they all had an understanding of
analytics so they wouldn't
you know they would rely on the analyst
for a deep dive of let's fix some
underlying things but they could read a
report they could understand it quickly
and they could communicate to the
clients very quickly um so that was uh i
would say the basic structure and then
we
uh honestly for any of the
uh
i would say them like paid search
sometimes we did that in-house but for
other projects we would go get a company
that specialized in paid search um
because we had the budget and based on
the client type it just made sense to
pay someone else to do it as a partner
uh and do that so
i
i would say i focused more on
high-level
communicators who understood content
content creation content distribution
uh
as well as high levels of interface with
clients and all of them have the ability
to do analytics
okay um we're coming up on uh
going 15 minutes over so i'm going to
ask one last question all right um so
that we don't keep you all day long but
and i apologize in advance for
the all the questions we could not get
to
um
we
we really got a lot of great questions
and and we would be here literally all
day if that was
um but the last question i want to ask
is
um
where
nashua from youtube asked where do i
learn the skills to be a successful
digital marketer
hey they're everywhere um you're on a
simply learn webinar and simply learn is
one of the the major training companies
um
they've got a certified certification uh
of digital marketing and it covers a lot
of different disciplines
um there are training companies all over
and i would look for training companies
that have a
a certification that um
that is an industry accepted
certification
um so
you know there are many things uh that
you can look at um you check out my site
as well i've got some smaller training
things on there uh you can do linkedin
um but what i like is a curated approach
to learning where there is a specific
course and that course has some
assignments and so you're developing a
work product as well
and then you have that certification of
your skills at the end
i would not recommend
building your own curriculum off of
youtube
anyone can put a youtube video out there
and anyone can say anything that's not a
a third-party endorsed curriculum
uh that is anyone can do that so i look
for training companies that have a
specific
endorsed curriculum that they have put
together and saying this is the learning
track this is what you're going to learn
uh
that's where i would focus
great i just dropped a link into the uh
chat
about one of simply learns uh digital
marketing programs we have
as you mentioned matt we have different
courses for particular skills we also
have comprehensive
programs that cover a whole suite of
skills the one i dropped into the chat
is the postgraduate program in
partnership with purdue university so
you get the advantages of
alumni affiliation with purdue and and
you get
a capstone project with as you said work
product that can show off your your
skills
and your experience to your uh potential
employers
um can i jump in one second sure
all right one of the biggest questions i
get is i don't have experience and
employers want one or three years
experience
here's my response to that don't wait
start something now build your own
website um
one of the ways that i keep in touch is
i do a lot of
uh
i do work for charities i do work for
friends
um my neighbor
uh he's got a side business and and i
built a website for him uh and now i
market it it's don't wait
this is digital everything's right there
you have all the tools you need one of
the best things i i
i would have everyone who worked for me
start a blog
and on that blog monetize people were
monetizing through youtube uh they had
google ads they were selling products
there is no reason that you can't start
something right now
that shows your skills and that you can
benefit from and here's the bigger
benefit
you get a job you're still making money
with
this other project that you can maintain
for years and and grow it with you don't
wait you can do something that gets
experience right now
build your own site build something
that's yours and grow it over time uh
that that
the experience question stop
that that parallels uh the advice so
many of our
guest experts have given about
um
software development and
the idea of using your github
account to um
to show off the different kinds of uh
open source projects you've done on a
volunteer basis
builds up your uh
experience credibility uh i do want to
share with you one comment from david
who said
uh literally uh or quote unreal this is
very interesting to be prepared for 2022
so
with
that uh endorsement i'm going to to
thank everybody for um
for their questions and
uh matt i see
i think i see on the screen if my system
is caught up that you've got your
contact information available yep
um there yep so yeah you can get me on
linkedin you can subscribe to the
podcast
uh or the website there sitelogic.com
and if you're interested in picking up
teach new dogs old tricks uh it's all
about sales and marketing and how to
apply it in a digital world
yeah i love that title too
thank you
all right and there's the contact info
for simply learn
thank you so much we appreciate it i've
dropped your linkedin mat into the chat
uh so people can just click on that to
follow or connect with you and
uh please do follow and connect with us
on facebook
twitter
and linkedin
we're at simply learn
and
we look forward to seeing you at future
simply learn webinars in the coming year
um
on behalf of simply learn and matt
bailey i would like to offer you
our best wishes for
a great winter season if it's a holiday
season for you then please
accept our best wishes for a happy
holiday and
we look forward to a fantastic
2022.
so thanks again
you